Alright. I want to make a lookup that relates bands and stages.
>> Right.
>> So I've got it. I'm ready to drop it. Do
I drop it on bands or stages, I always forget this?
>>
[LAUGH]
So, when creating any relationship, whether it's Master Detail or Lookup
you should always create the relationship field on the child record.
>> Right. Each band I want to know.
This is the stage you're pla-, playing in.
>> Exactly.
>> because each stage is going to have a bagillion bands.
>> Yup.
>> All right. Okay, make sense. Right. So, Field Label, I'll call it stage.
>> Stage.
>> It's just the stage the band is playing
in. And the fun step is that it's related to
Stages. Cool. And it already populated this stuff. So, I
save. Haha. We got our line. We got our relationship. That's pretty cool.